i'm really so so humbled to see that
the whole report is steeped in deep
respect for us as families
and that's really touched me i'm very
grateful for that
so it's clear from the first report of
the inquiry
that venue security needs to be improved
to help prevent
further terrorist attacks i along with
other supporters of martin's law welcome
the recommendation
that ensuring sufficient protection and
preparation
for any potential incident is an
obligation for venue owners
the past nine months have been extremely
difficult for all of
the families as we listened to what
happened on that night
but now after this report we are one
step closer
to ensuring that the difference can be
made
now the recommendations have to be acted
upon by the government
so that all venues have basic security
and so that no other families
have to go through what we have i would
like to thank the inquiry staff
the staff the incredible judge
the authorities the government and all
of those who have helped champion
martin's law
but while the report focuses on venue
security
martin's law goes beyond this to make
the safety of
all public venues a priority we should
not have to live in fear
and i'm determined to make this law a
reality
thank you and i'd say in the words of
us sir john saunders in the report to
all the policy makers and decision
makers out there
doing nothing is not an option
definitely thank you